hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Treasure Island now a surprising number
of people actually really wanted to see
the second night I don't know if there's
going to be any more nights after that
but I also am kind of curious so I will
be wait a minute no no I was on night 2
damn it
ok well it seems that I have to play
through night one again so I'll be back
at night - ok guys welcome to night two
here's the phone call that I overrode
the last episode let's listen in hello
oh hey Jake it's me Lisa so from I heard
Greg left a pre-recorded message
yesterday
and I for one think what he said was
pretty stupid I'm sorry we stopped to
get our equipment ready it hasn't been
shipped in yet so we're still waiting we
basically want you to collect data for
us when we come over there it'll be
easier to maintain everything oh and
also fake as always has left out some
details from his last message he said
that the photo negative suit can't see
but it can it can't see but not too oh
so do not make any noise if you have to
that would be a really bad idea
ok also I don't think he told you about
Oswald and you're not gonna like this
the Oslo she was never finished but it's
said to walk around just like the other
suit but the thing is is that his colors
and textures were never finished so he's
really black which means he can't be
seen that easily I'm sorry I'm not sure
if you can do anything about him but I
doubt he'll be a problem since he has no
arms but if he starts becoming a
nuisance
men just show up your cams like you do
it with you for Mickey that should do it
uh-huh but all right I wish you luck
okay thanks for the luck that's really
gonna help me when diabolical machines
are trying to rip my face off I'm
assuming that this over here okay you're
really talkative today as much as I like
conversation I'm trying to talk to my
audience they need my undivided
attention to okay he's gone well
Oswald as I'm assuming that actually is
Oswald is on the move and he's somewhere
I don't know where they said that he was
missing textures which is something to
do with the game and not necessarily
like anything else wait could he be in
the darkness there and I can't see him
have mercy on Twiggs okay I'll do all of
that
wait what oh wait there there there
there
right there right there exactly there
he's got a bottom okay Donald's head was
decided pay me a visit I guess is he in
there wait okay so I shut off Oh nimmy
okay so Donald's head is back is he in
there I'm not gonna be able to see him
when he comes over to get me I don't
want him to rip my giblets out of my
face I'm keeping they're not wait okay I
thought I saw something
how am I gonna even be able to tell this
one incandescent bulb is not gonna be
enough to illuminate my surroundings I
need
or I need much whoa oh don't mess with
me how about that how about don't mess
with me now my voice isn't exactly a
hundred percent but as you can see it's
getting a little bit better than it was
yesterday so I'm still gonna take it
generally easy and get my voice into the
old Western saloon owner and possibly in
emergencies dip it down into Optimus
Prime range because the Decepticon
Menace on my throats is too great to die
don't know okay I need to have my camera
uh-huh yeah keep talking there buddy
I may have to bust out Optimus Prime on
you whatever the cost I know now saloon
owner I don't know what I'm doing at the
moment have mercy on twigs I only ask
for bosoms don't we all don't we all
just want bosoms in our life why don't
you take one of the girls and just have
a night off I swear if he's hiding in
the darkness and I can't see him I'm
going to be very upset okay so Mickey's
back there mister okay yeah you you need
to stop talking now
cuz III see him I see him I see him I
said I saw him he was right there he was
right there did that take care of him
he's gone now I'm assuming that did yes
okay
another unknown factor here so I got
three cameras out it's true
whoa he's back what the hell he was
supposed to be gone oh don't mess with
me
yes I know you keep saying don't mess
but maybe you're saying don't make a
mess maybe it's like get our armstrong's
message when he was on the moon God he's
back again I'm gonna run out of cameras
at this point it's gotta be a way to get
him to go away permanently unless I'm
just going to run out of cameras it's
only 4:00 a.m. I think I have one left I
know they come back at some point but I
don't know how long that takes
hi God bored Gary Gary the deuce
maybe you're Gary maybe I'm Gary
maybe I'm the purple man from five
nights at Freddy's maybe all of this is
starting to make sense okay so it seems
like Goofy's camera is almost
permanently out okay I gotta like move
around it's very dark I don't want to be
caught off guard oh no I don't know if
if there was anyone there but I don't
want to be caught completely damn it I
am trying to stay calm here you [ __ ] oh
thank goodness it goes tonight too but
god damn it okay i stupid flippy-floppy
camera controls
oh my Greg left you he recorded message
yesterday and I for one think what he
said was pretty stupid well alright then
now we're going to get back into it and
now you're going to get off to miss
Bryer
hope the miss blonde doesn't have any
well I think that's dipping into Santa
actually I can't focus on what ball hey
Mickey how you doing nice ears you have
there why don't you go screw yourself
what the [ __ ] was that that was
different that was a different noise was
that Oswald I'd like to think that
Oswald is a walking pair of legs with a
butt attached to it and nothing else
doesn't want anyone to see him for be
half north I know I think many nights on
car behaves nah
it weighs heavily on my soul I just got
to be very careful with the camera I got
careless last time and that's what costs
105 and if I do double flip it like that
go away
[Music]
always making noise Oh God
oh I don't know what to do now that said
oh you went away before okay he went
away finally after I shut up five of my
cameras he took away five of them so how
the hell am I gonna survive now I've
only got one I only got one camera left
and this one which doesn't actually show
anything okay I'm just going to have to
be careful manage Marta I don't know if
they can pop up here I mean Donald did I
just heard the noise though so that
means the noise came before he got here
and then they have bug things out a
little bit and caused him not to go away
but I'm still at risk so you know
frankly I don't give a damn I'm just
going to be very cool okay I've got a
camera back that's good and Oswald is
still in the walking pair of butt cheeks
I guess is still in his place I also
have to remember that after I put the
camera down
[Music]
Gorby Afsar does if he is there then I
need to be able to see him hey all my
cameras are back I guess actually didn't
do anything so we didn't actually lead
it away he's a controlling weight okay I
need to wash this out
go to hell this has a dick
I may be gonna do it cuz there we go
called about damn time
The Donald darkness of this place socks
nests of this security guard er just a
night watchman why don't I have like a
gun a damn gun would be very useful in
this situation if you don't mind me
saying so making an Oswald are actually
being the least active here I can see
they're not entirely intending to kill
me which is a good thing cuz I would
punch them right in the face I would
punch them so hard Mickey's ears would
blast away into the little dinner plates
at them in the darkness oh if you if you
if you dick with me Oswald I will dick
back with you and don't take that the
wrong way don't take it the right way
either because I'm not sure there's any
other way there could be taken just
don't take it at all
don't take my Dickens I don't think
that's it nevermind I'm gonna stop
talking now I knew I had more ear man
Mickey was mad what to worry about very
dumb I don't want to see your head come
off do you go please let that have been
fast enough I don't want to see your
head come off okay alright then I did it
I did it I don't want to see your head
come on I think my mouse is dying keeps
fiddling on me yeah
jump it all over the place not what I'm
this close Mouse something about when I
play this game mice go against me nice
trying to no I do not are you here I
don't want to see your head come off
have a feeling you gonna pop up that was
surprisingly stressful five nights at
Treasure Island demo the only completed
up tonight to the game is still under
development develop in mint but it's
surprisingly almost done this game to
not be sold or bought for the
copyrighted Disney will not allow it nor
will I the Disney ideas and concepts
this game was inspired by the made by
cop Scott Cawthon owner of i90 Freddy
for the rest of the game go to my TBR
page blah blah blah there he's been
linked in the description below I was
actually shocked I was startled by
things I was creeped out and I had a
little bit of anxiety there I don't know
why I always default to the saloon owner
when I play this game but hopefully that
will rectify itself in future endeavors
so thank you all so much for watching
check out other videos I've done in the
description lower the annotations that
appear over there thanks again everybody
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
I kind of wanted to talk to